Donald Trump has reportedly been exhibiting
even stranger behavior in private, going on
childish tirades against his generals, including
calling them dopes and babies behind closed
doors and criticizing the United States military
is one he would not want to go to war with.
This is truly stunning.
There's a book coming out tomorrow called
a very stable genius, Donald J Trump's testing
of America.
It's been written by two authors, Carol Carol
Lennon and Phillip Rutger.
And there's an article that's been adapted
from the book published and it's either the
stuff of a really funny political sketch comedy
show or in this case since it's not fiction
but about the real world.
It is absolutely the stuff of horrors.
The incident in question happened six months
into Donald Trump's administration, and it's
important to remember that at the time Jim
Mattis was still secretary of defense, no
bleeding heart liberal, a sensible guy with
a worldview that does not match mine.
Not a guy that will be pushed around though.
And on July 20th of 2017 Donald Trump met
with secretary Jim Mattis, his then secretary
of state.
Rex Tillerson was also at the meeting, also
gone now.
Gary Cohn, Trump's former economic advisor
was also, they're also gone now and the point
of the meeting was to talk about what is going
to happen with Iran, how are we going to handle
the Iran situation? Trump was already planning
on bailing on the Iran deal, which he eventually
did.
As we now know, the meeting took place at
the Pentagon.
Chairman of the joint chiefs was at the meeting,
deputy defense secretary at the meeting.
A lot of leaders of military branches were
at this meeting.
This is an important meeting.
These are the generals that we heard so much
about Trump's respect, respect for and all
of that stuff.
They planned the briefing with lots of maps
and pictures to try to keep Donald Trump's
attention, which is always a challenge and
as soon as the meeting started because of
the tone of it and the direction, Steve Bannon
who was in the room immediately thought, this
is not going to go well.
Donald Trump is not going to like this.
The meeting went on for 90 minutes.
Trump's attention span was like that of a
fruit fly, interrupting constantly with nonsequitors.
I won't list all of Donald Trump's interruptions
because we'd be here all day, but they were
really dumb and eventually things exploded.
Trump started to say, other countries are
worthless.
NATO was worthless.
The conversation kept escalating.
Trump said, I want out of the Iran deal.
It's the worst deal in history.
Tillerson, again, not a bleeding heart liberal,
but a guy who every once in a while would
interject some sanity into Donald Trump's
thought process.
Tillerson tries to say, well, you know, actually
it's a, and Trump says, I don't want to hear
it.
They're cheating.
I want to get out of it.
They try to talk about Iran and Trump explodes
again saying, Afghanistan's terrible.
That's a loser war.
And then Trump attacks the generals and Trump
says, you're all losers.
You don't know how to win anymore.
And then Trump is really in a rage and goes
into personal attacks saying, quote, I wouldn't
go to war with you people.
You're a bunch of dopes and babies, draft
Dodger, Trump telling a room full of generals
that they are the dopes and the babies.
Everyone in the room was reportedly stunned.
Tillerson was visibly furious.
Nadis was reportedly speechless and just staring
straight down at the table.
That military thing appear apparently of this
is the commander in chief, and I can't really
lose my mind on him, but I can't stand what's
going on.
Reportedly just staring down at the table.
Even Mike Pence was reportedly and still like
a statue seemingly trying to blend into the
background.
Rex Tillerson later said that there was a
woman in the room who was crying in a corner
while this was going on.
And eventually Rex Tillerson defended the
generals and defended the military.
And this is the incident that reportedly later
led to Rex Tillerson uttering that now famous
phrase that Donald Trump is a moron, which
remember was sort of the beginning of the
end of Rex Tillerson's secretary a ship with
a, with Donald Trump.
Uh, and a comment that he later did not deny
when given the opportunity that he called
Trump a moron.
So in a world that's still made sense, Donald
Trump voters that claim to support the troops
would hear about this and they would be outraged
because this is not supporting the troops.
This is cadet bone, spurs the mango menace,
disrespecting the entire military apparatus
at the highest level.
Of course, Trump has to have been so successfully
primed to believe that anything negative about
Donald Trump is fake news, that it probably
will make no impact on them whatsoever.
And I, I don't know that I need to say this,
but I will.
I don't agree with many of the missions of
the military.
I disagree with many of the ways in which
the military is deployed.
But when Donald Trump, who grew up with a
silver spoon in his mouth, who assembles his
top generals, who are people that went to
school, they've had training, they've had
vetting, they've done practical work, they've
been deployed in many cases and Trump says,
I wouldn't go to war with you guys, your dopes
and babies.
This is weaponized ignorance.
It's weaponized narcissism.
And this is the danger of Trump that he assembles
his generals as he calls them.
And he still believes he knows more than them
when what they're saying doesn't go along
with his completely harebrained preconceived
notions.
Every one of his so called America first supporters
should be abandoning Donald Trump over this,
but it won't happen.
We know that it won't because of cognitive
dissonance, because of successfully priming
his followers to disbelieve anything.
That sounds like Donald Trump did the wrong
thing and what you, you know again, can we
remove the sky in November?
I don't know, but we damn well better try
because it's getting really, really bad out
there to make sure to follow me on Twitter
at D Pacman.
You want to see how bad it's getting?
Checkout my hate mail posts from this morning.
Follow me again
and let me know what you think about this
latest report